so we have a panicked situation
happening though but Joe Biden's putting
out proposals which we've already talked
about on the other side Donald Trump has
replaced this campaign manager Brad Parr
scale with only three and a half months
to go in the campaign now Donald Trump
is framing this as this is great I'm
doing this because it's just all so
wonderful I'm gonna show you in a moment
how Donald Trump is presenting this
change but make no mistake don't be
confused you only replace your campaign
manager three-and-a-half months before
the election if you're panicking and
things are going terribly and I'll
actually give you an example in a moment
of the last time a sitting president
replaced their campaign manager three
and a half months before the election
now to back up a little bit
rumors have been swirling about Donald
Trump being furious with his campaign
manager Brad Parr scale for a while I
think it was about two months ago when
the polling started to go south for
Trump there were leaks from the White
House that on a Friday night Donald
Trump was in the Oval Office on the
phone with Brad Parr scale screaming at
him and I'm paraphrasing here saying how
the F am I losing to Joe Biden and it's
been downhill from there both in terms
of the virus and Trump's polling and now
Brad Parr scale is out formally they're
calling this just a reorganization as
usual Trump is trying to put a positive
spin on everything he does tweeting last
night around 9:00 p.m. that quote I am
pleased to announce that Bill Stepien
has been promoted to the role of Trump
campaign manager Brad parse Cal who has
been with me for a very long time and
has led our tremendous digital and data
strategies will remain in that role
while being a senior adviser to the
campaign both were heavily involved in
our historic 2016 win and I look forward
to having a big and very important
second win together this one should be a
lot easier as our poll numbers are
rising fast that's not true the economy
is getting better vaccines and
therapeutics will soon be on the way and
Americans want safe streets and
communities so let me interpret for you
Trump realizes straight up firing his
campaign manager would look very very
bad so instead he says hey we're just
gonna shift things around Brad parce
qu'elle is not going to be campaign
manager anymore but it'll keep doing
digital stuff because he's so good there
but we're putting in
place a different campaign manager but
everything's great and everything's
hunky-dory this is a firing and your
file at firing someone who has failed
but you're finding a way to do it that
maybe doesn't look as panicked and the
reality is Trump should be panicked
because his approval is down to 36% in
the latest Quinnipiac poll we'll talk
about that later 1,000 coronavirus
deaths in the United States yesterday
for the first time since June 9th so
it's been five weeks since the US had a
thousand coronavirus deaths in a day we
had it yesterday it's tragic
other countries have figured it out this
is unnecessary loss of life and the new
poll out yesterday shows that 62% of
Americans believe that Donald Trump is
actually hurting the coronavirus
response rather than being a force for
good when it comes to the coronavirus
response our friend bill scher pointed
out to me on Twitter this morning that
the last time a sitting president I know
that in 2016 in the summer Trump changed
campaign managers but and now I'm
talking about the last time a sitting
president who was running for
re-election replace their campaign
manager this late in the game was in
1992 when George HW Bush Bush 41
replaced his campaign manager in the
summer we know how that turned out
Bush 41 lost to Bill Clinton just a few
months later and importantly we also
haven't had an incumbent president who
was this far behind in the polls three
and a half months before an election
since 1992 either now in terms of the
actual staff change and the strategy
here from Donald Trump I don't know what
parse scales replacement bill Stepien is
going to be able to do right now
remember that Stepien was the guy fired
by former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie in that entire Bridgegate
debacle that's a different story but if
Stepien was too incompetent for chris
christie I don't know how he helps
Donald Trump Stepien is good friends
with Jared Kushner there's speculation
that that's really what what this is
maybe about hilariously remember that
Trump claims that all of the polls that
have him losing our fake suppression
polls and he actually tweeted he's going
up in the polls
that's the case if you believe you're
winning why would you take out of power
your campaign manager who has you
winning it's because Trump knows that
he's in trouble and I actually don't
think that Brad Parr scale is the
problem I don't think parse scale is a
particularly good campaign manager he is
a good data an analytics guy but the
problem is not strategy here the problem
is that Trump has failed on coronavirus
and everything else that has gone on and
again the easiest way to win this
election for Trump would have been in
January in February to start properly
handling coronavirus from the beginning
it literally takes months to get
outbreaks under control time is running
out right we're in mid-july and Texas is
peaking Florida speaking they're going
up they may not even have peaked yet it
takes 8 to 10 weeks to flatten the cases
and then an additional 20 days to
flatten deaths we're at election day
right understand that the timeline is if
all these states did everything
perfectly starting today we are at
election day before the numbers really
get under control and so all Trump has
left his dirty tricks remember that
understand that let me know where you
are on this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
we had I know I told you this last week
and I told you this the day the week
before and the week before yesterday
Wednesday was the best day ever for the
David Pakman show YouTube channel and
the David Pakman show audio podcast you
go back to the beginning of the show
yesterday was the best day on both of
those platforms and just a reminder if
you like consuming the show in a longer
form format get the audio podcast for
free on stitcher google play iTunes
Pandora Spotify etc etc wherever you
prefer we'll take a quick break and be
back after this if you are anything like
me you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into a doctor's office
right now and thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health and get
personalized care from the comfort of
your home it's a service called
steady m.d they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician who
understands your health needs you have a
one-hour video call with your new doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call each doctor at steady MD
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you you
get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations talk to you about health
concerns send prescriptions to your home
or local pharmacy and anything they
can't do online they'll quickly set you
up with an in-person provider to do
things like blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays there are so many practical
advantages to using steady MD for
primary care and it's also so much more
affordable go to steady MD comm slash
Pakman to take the free quiz see which
doctor is right for you I took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor who
specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started just click the
link right underneath this video